JEDEDIAH: THIS HOLIDAY WEEKEND
JOE BIDEN CONTINUING HIS VIRTUAL
CAMPAIGN FROM THE BASEMENT OF
HIS DELAWARE HOME.
TRUMP’S CAMPAIGN PLANS TO FLY
AERIAL KEEP AMERICA GREAT
BANNERS OVER U.S. BEACHES.
GRIFF: SO WHO’S GOT THE WINNING
STRATEGY?
LET’S BRING IN FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND FORMER G.O.P.
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE AND
GOVERNOR MIKE HUCKABEE.
MIKE, TELL US, WHAT DO YOU MAKE
-- I’VE GOT TO GO TO THIS BIDEN
THING BECAUSE REALLY THIS IS NOT
THE FIRST TIME.
IT IS OBVIOUSLY CONTINUED
ABILITY TO MAKE THESE GAFFES BUT
NOW FOR THE FIRST TIME HE’S
BEING CALLED ON IT BY
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY FOR
HIS MISTAKES.
BUT YET BIDEN CONTINUES FROM THE
BASEMENT TO SAY HE’S GOING TO
WIN.
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK JOE’S
BASEMENT CAMPAIGN IS SOMEWHAT
MAYBE STATISTIC OF HIS WHOLE
APPROACH TO BEING PRESIDENT.
IF HE WERE TO BE ELECTED, WE’D
ALL BE IN THE BASEMENT.
I MEAN, THAT’S THE PROBLEM WITH
JOE.
THIS IS A GUY WHO HAS SPENT THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS IN THE
BASEMENT.
I JUST SAW A COMMERCIAL
YESTERDAY, JOAN LUNDEN WAS
TALKING ABOUT A PLACE FOR JOE.
IT’S WHERE YOU PUT ALL YOUR
CRANKY RELATIVES DOWN IN THE
BASEMENT AND KEEP ’EM OUT OF
SIGHT BECAUSE EVERY TIME HE
SURFACES -- AND IT’S KIND OF
LIKE, YOU KNOW, PUCKS TAWNY PHIL
THE GROUNDHOG, HE COMES OUT,
SEES HIS SHADOW, MAKES A GAFFE
AND THEN BE SPENDS THE NEXT
THREE DAYS WITH HE AND HIS STAFF
APOLOGIZING FOR WHAT HE SAID.
SO HE’S BETTER OFF JUST SENDING
SOME WRITTEN MESSAGES OR
LEARNING TO HAVE SOMEONE DO HIS
VOICE AND LET HIM LIP-SYNCH
BECAUSE WHEN HE GOES JUST OFF
THE SCRIPT IT’S DISASTROUS AS
WE’VE SEEN THIS WEEK.
JEDEDIAH: GOVERNOR, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF PRESIDENT TRUMP TALKING
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE REOPENING
OF CHURCHES AND SAYING THAT HE’S
WILLING TO OVERRIDE GOVERNORS
WHO DON’T ALLOW THESE PLACES OF
WORSHIP TO OPEN THIS WEEKEND?
THERE’S BEEN A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
WOULD HE EVEN BE ABLE TO DO THAT
BUT WHAT DO YOU MAKE ABOUT HIS
STATEMENT ABOUT HIS WILLINGNESS
TO DO SO?
>> WELL, HOW GRATEFUL I AM TO
HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO RECOGNIZES
THE FIRST AMENDMENT OF THE
CONSTITUTION THAT GIVES
AMERICANS TWO BASIC FUNDAMENTAL
FREEDOMS AND SAYS THE GOVERNMENT
CAN’T STOP IT.
ONE IS PEACEFUL ASSEMBLY.
RELIGION.
HE HAS TAKEN AN AFFIRMATIVE
STANCE FOR BOTH.
HE’S ALSO RECOGNIZED THAT IT’S
RIDICULOUS FOR SOME OF THESE
BLUE STATE GOVERNORS TO SAY THAT
YOU CAN GO HAVE AN ABORTION BUT
YOU CAN’T GO HAVE PRAYER, THAT
YOU CAN GO TO A BIG BOX STORE,
WALK AROUND HUNDREDS OF TOTAL
STRANGERS, RUB SHOULDERS WITH
THEM WITH OUR WITHOUT MASKS, BUT
YOU CAN’T GO TO A CHURCH BEING
VERY CAREFUL MAKING SURE PEOPLE
SOCIAL DISTANCE, THAT YOU DON’T
TOUCH DOOR HANDLES, ALL OF THE
THINGS CHURCHES ARE DOING.
BUT PEOPLE NEED SPIRIT GUIDANCE.
THEY NEED A SENSE OF PURPOSE AND
THEY GET THAT FROM CHURCH.
I WOULD CONTEND THAT CHURCH IS
GIVING PEOPLE A FAR GREATER
SENSE OF LIFE THAN MAYBE GOING
TO A SUPERMARKET WOULD.
CERTAINLY CERTAIN THINGS HAVE TO
BE PURCHASED.
BUT THE PRESIDENT IS DOING THE
RIGHT THING.
AS TO WHETHER HE CAN ORDER THE
GOVERNORS, HERE’S HOW -- THE
ONLY WAY I KNOW HE COULD DO IT
WOULD BE THAT HE WOULD HAVE THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DEMAND THAT
THEY SIMPLY REQUIRE IT AND FILE
A LAWSUIT AGAINST ANY GOVERNOR
OR ANY LOCAL COMMUNITY THAT SAYS
THAT THEY CANNOT OPEN A CHURCH
IF THEY’RE OPENING EVERYTHING
ELSE BECAUSE THE FACT IS THAT
SHOWS RELIGIOUS DISCRIMINATION.
THAT’S NOT ALLOWED, AND I THINK
THE PRESIDENT WOULD BE WITHIN
HIS RIGHTS TO SICK THE D.O.J. ON
.
GRIFF: WELL, YOU’RE CERTAINLY
RIGHT.
I WAS AT A GROCERY STORE
YESTERDAY, GOVERNOR.
IT WAS NOT LIFE GIVING.
IT WAS SOUL CRUSHING.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
READY FOR THOSE CHURCHES TO BE
OPEN TO CONGREGATE WITH FELLOW
WORSHIPERS.
BUT I WANT TO ASK ABOUT A TOUGH
STORY WE HEARD THIS MORNING, ONE
OF YOUR FRIENDS, FRIENDS OF MANY
OF US, ALLEN WEST WAS IN A
MOTORCYCLE ACCIDENT, AND YOU’RE
MORNING.
>> YOU KNOW, ALLEN WEST IS A
DEAR FRIEND.
I LOVE HIM.
I SO RESPECT HIM.
LIKE YOU HE’S A COMBAT VETERAN.
HE PUT ON THE UNIFORM OF THIS
COUNTRY, HE WENT AND SERVED, HE
PUT HIS LIFE AT TERRIFIC AND
TODAY, YOU KNOW, HE’S STRUGGLING
AND COMING THROUGH THE AFTERMATH
OF A MOTORCYCLE ACCIDENT NEAR
WACO, TEXAS, YESTERDAY.
STILL WAITING ON WORD THIS
MORNING OF ANY UPDATE ON HIS
CONDITION.
HE WAS STABLE LAST NIGHT.
LET’S PRAY THAT HE HAS FULL
RECOVERY.
HE’S RUNNING FOR THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY OF TEXAS.
I JUST THINK HE’S ONE OF THE
GREAT PATRIOTS OF OUR TIME.
AND I KNOW THAT ALL FOX &
FRIENDS VIEWERS JOIN ME IN
.
GRIFF: LIEUTENANT COLONEL ALLEN
WEST, GREAT AMERICAN.
I KNOW WE WILL BE JOINING YOU IN
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS FOR HIM
TODAY.
GOVERNOR, REAL QUICK YOUR
MEMORIAL DAY MESSAGE.
>> LET’S NOT FORGET WHY WE HAVE
THIS HOLIDAY.
LET’S ENJOY IT.
ENJOY THE BEACHES, THE LAKES,
THE PARKS, ALL THE THINGS, THE
BARBECUES.
BUT AS YOU CELEBRATE FREEDOM
REMEMBER THAT IT WAS NOT FREE TO
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO GAVE THEIR LIVES FOR US TO
HAVE THIS FREEDOM.
LET’S CHERISH IT, PROTECT IT,
AND PASS IT ON TO THE NEXT
GENERATION.